I know that in space one of the dangers
for astronauts they don't want liquid
floating around because you could
accidentally inhale it and you could
choke on it
so she should probably be careful of
that here my name is Jason Rhodes and
I'm an astrophysicist
my name is Alena Aisling and I am an
astrophysicist Alena and I are gonna be
reviewing movies about space today we
both watch a sci-fi movies I'm a fan of
Star Trek and Star Wars and I like
sci-fi even if it isn't always entirely
believable so this is the movie gravity
I remember when we saw this movie I
thought in every scene if this movie was
realistic she would have died in every
scene absolutely this was actually a
difficult one to watch from a science
perspective you could see a tear
drifting away from from her face of
course water doesn't roll down your face
in zero-gravity and it would ball up
like that and float away well I think
that maybe it would get stuck in her eye
and she would actually have to move it
out that wouldn't be nearly as cinematic
no it wouldn't with the tear the
accuracy there is really close to an 8
out of 10 the movie itself is closer to
a 1 out of 10 place she'd be dead every
time say we've got the maybe
interstellar heels and they're talking
about getting away from a black hole
shed the weight just came to gravity
Newton's third law the only way humans
have ever figured out of getting
somewhere is to leave something behind
there's a law of conservation of
momentum in space if I were to throw
something this way I would start to move
this way and that's what they're talking
about doing would it not immediately
suck you it
it wouldn't necessarily immediately suck
you in but if you did get sucked into a
black hole if you got sucked in
feet-first your feet would be pulled so
much harder than your head you'd
literally be pulled apart but it's kind
of cool what Jason was just talking
about how's the name officially
spaghettification you turn into a piece
of spaghetti because it stretches you
out I do know that the animations here
were meant to be quite realistic some of
my colleagues did some computer
simulations of what they thought things
would look like and they tried to make
these as realistic as possible they
probably made it a little more cinematic
than it would be in real life I would
say it's maybe an 8 out of 10 which to
me is about as high as I've ever seen a
science fiction movie go yeah they had
really good science consultants on this
dome who we actually know and recently
won a Nobel Prize yeah all right so
we're watching passengers yeah but we
haven't seen this one mystique from the
x-men has just woken up I guess and
she's going for a swim in a spaceship
that's pretty awesome
[Music]
Oh have any less okay so it stopped
spinning I guess and so water is
starting to leave the pole she might be
in some trouble yes
just like in gravity if she were to to
swim and push against it she could get
to the edge now gravity is turning back
on in the ship Oh everybody's falling
including the water it wouldn't wouldn't
happen quite that fast unless something
caused it to stop spinning it would just
keep spinning something would have to
actively work against the spin and that
would take a lot of energy and I would
imagine it would take a lot more time
with a structure that size passengers on
a scale of one to ten for the clip we
just saw I think I'm giving it about a
six out of ten you're more generous to
me I was going to go with the floor okay
maybe that's in comparison to
interstellar where they really tried to
make it as realistic as possible we're
watching guardians at the galaxies and
we've got Gamora on the scene at the
moment if she was human she'd be dead
already
[Music]
and he opened the pod door and we didn't
see any air escaping and we didn't see
the pod going the other way as the air
rushed out his skin is freezing which is
accurate except he's not dead and his
eyes are still working they would have
frozen instantly but then like he's half
God right that's true his father is a
sentient planet so he has that going for
him and now I'm there in a pressurized
atmosphere and totally fine sorry that
didn't seem to hit them at all
no I've read somewhere and I don't
remember where that I think you could
live for a few seconds in vacuum but I
think you wouldn't quite recover this
quickly if ten I would give it about a 1
I would give it a 2 keep in mind this is
accuracy we loved the movie yeah I loved
it
scientific accuracy that's it well yeah
I want to go home too much this again
down all right we're watching the last
Jedi I think Carrie Fisher CGI
oh he had second thoughts not blowing up
his mother
[Music]
there was an explosion and everything
was sucked out of the hole that was
created by the explosion that's pretty
accurate
like with star-lord and Gamora Princess
Leia's skin is starting to freeze and
she's wisely not open to her hands she's
also a geyser I sorry open her eyes now
she's I should memorize and they are not
raisin
so when you're allowed to use the force
all bets are off yeah physics doesn't
have to be obeyed
[Music]
they opened a door and what would have
happened really is that lots of air
would have rushed out into the vacuum of
space and probably pushed her out again
yeah and the people that were right
there at that door when it opened I
imagined that they would have also been
like sucked out pretty violently yes out
of ten for Star Wars I am giving it a
one again one or two maybe two maybe a
two because the air flew out in the
first explosion all right we're looking
at the movie Total Recall here but I
haven't seen it
oh and they've lost gravity sorry and
everyone started to float yep they lost
the gravity very quickly okay they shot
their guns and they didn't move
backwards which is somewhat accurate but
unless you were shooting the gun from
exactly your center of gravity instead
of just moving in one direction you
would start to spin yeah
and he's using the gun really has a
jetpack to move around it's like they
attended maybe the first semester of
physics and learned about things going
in a straight line and then didn't
attend the next semester of physics
where you might learn about how to
calculate things that are rotating Colin
Farrell would have started spinning
quite rapidly every time he fired that
gun on a scale of one to ten Total
Recall I'm gonna give six because they
did do conservation of momentum it's
gonna go a little lower for that five
but somewhere in the middle if they
tried
all right this is the movie wall-e
there's a lot of sound I don't know how
they would be having so much sound
there's no atmosphere to carry the sound
in space and there was a plant that they
brought out into the vacuum and that
plant seemed to be perfectly healthy
yeah I think that plant would have not
done well if it had any moisture in it
at all
the idea that you could push yourself
with a fire extinguisher
is true the way he's using it is not
very realistic I think to have a lot of
control where I think that that level of
control would not be possible for me the
efficacy of wall-e on a scale of 1 to 10
I'm gonna give it 5
I think I'm harsher than you I was gonna
say a 2 or a 3 maybe they were showing
that while he could use the fire
extinguisher to move around but changing
directions far too much for very
accurate kids cartoon i mean ii mean
angular momentum we're represented
that's true
so maybe I'm being too harsh overall I
think that maybes frequently get it
wrong but that's not why I watch them
I'm willing to also you know suspend my
disbelief if it's a good story it makes
me happy when the science is right and
people can learn from it but it isn't a
necessary condition for a movie to be
good
[Music]